what can you tell us about their
quarterly results alright so the results
are confusing and and I want to jump
right in here because the company said
they were in a Cell 11,000 127 cars at
least in the fourth quarter the end of
the last third quarter they said we're
lowering our target of cars ship from
35,000 to 33,000 but don't war we're
going to get to 33,000 means 11,000 call
it 200 they sold only 9,000 834 but they
introduce this new metric at the top of
their press release of how many cars
they produced in the quarter of eleven
thousand 627 so if you glanced at the
release he said hey I'm looking for
11200 they got 11,000 627 that's great
buy this stock they beat the number well
they missed the number i sold a lot
fewer cars then then their guidance had
been and that many on Wall Street were
looking for they're blaming it on
production problems with their new dual
drive p85 d they're saying 1400 orders
slipped into the next quarter that they
just couldn't get those cars made but
the bottom line is they made more cars
than they sold him you and I talked
about whether or not there was there was
demand for these cars above and beyond
what they could make well they made more
than they could sell so that tells me
that there's a backlog and the stock has
been whipping up and down and up and
down again in after-hours trading but
fundamentally they sold fewer cars in
the growth rate sequentially which that
which wall she thought to be forty five
percent was only about twenty six
percent of the number of cars that they
sold in the quarter and the loss an
enormous loss the biggest loss I've ever
had at Tesla since they started making
the Model S so you know a quarter that
was not what the most bullish people
thought it might be in the in the fourth
quarter of 2014 Corey the shares of
tesla down about two percent in the
after-hours trade let's just put this
into perspective current market value of
tesla about twenty six point six billion
dollars that makes it ten billion
dollars more valuable based on the stock
market than a company like Kia they
produced three million cars last year
you're saying that all right they had
trouble getting to thirty three thousand
cars at Tesla is test I really a tech
stock not really an automotive stock the
stock yes the company I don't know I
mean isn't every company in tech company
who has more technology Tesla or Ford I
don't know the answer to that I think
it's traded with the expectation of
fantastic growth but what we can see
from the results at first glance hear of
it and I will I will also say they they
pushed back the time for the conference
call these earnings came out we're
supposed to come out of the top of the
hour came back you know New York time 5
15 or so so pretty late they gave you
any insight into what's going on with
the Model X weren't they say that that
was going to be delivered in the third
quarter of 2015 that's the four-wheel
drive SUV they say it's going to ship in
the next six months I've seen various
reports of some test drives happening
arise in secret locations around here in
the bay area including the Alameda Naval
Base across the bay from us here at
Bloomberg they say that while they now
understand they announces great fanfare
this is this d 85 that they couldn't
even ship in the quarter but they're
saying that the development remains on
plans for initial customer deliveries of
Model X in q3 that's been pushed back a
few times but they say that 30 beta
models have been built or undergoing
testing right now and you know maybe
there's some excitement over that
product that SUV hitting the market on
time but what we can see from these
results is the last car they said would
be on time isn't and they're having
production problems there maybe the next
one will be on top